hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley is that shirt you're gonna wear
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
are you garbage a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
found it if they grow up to be classy
or just a big old piece of trash yeah
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at aunt
hoody's basement
haven't seen her in a couple of days
yeah she's out and about
a lincoln town car picked her up a
couple nights ago for a romantic weekend
down in atlantic city
bobby you think it's bobby lambs i think
it's bobby lamb
all right he might have some company
moving in upstairs and if he comes in he
might kick us the [ __ ] out
he might bring chas around he might he
might send us to boarding school or
something like that
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of are you
garbage he has a brand new
chase corporate card that gets me wet in
the underwear i can tell you that right
now
i call him mr ryan you know him as kippy
give it up for kevin
james brian everybody hey hey moneybags
[Laughter]
by the way away this weekend with the
friends posting some pictures
of some fancy ipas yeah we should have
that
card in glass somewhere break in case of
emergency yeah foley as if he was
getting a card
uh a card to the company bank account i
was like absolutely not
that you'd be getting like well the
netflix subscription was bouncing so i
had to [ __ ]
i'm like no way dude no way guys happy
to be here thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and those numbers
are what
true the roof through the [ __ ] roof
and then good patreon.com those numbers
are [ __ ] cooking almost
10 grand i don't like to talk money but
we're almost at 10 grand a month
uh and then you guys can sign up there
you get bonus episodes of ayg hard
feelings and live streams wherever we
play you ask us questions we ask you
questions it's a good [ __ ] time
one of them coming up soon can't wait
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire
he makes us all look good he's the magic
man he is t-boned mcmuffin to his
friends
but the government knows him as tobias
martin
xavier mcmullen everybody what uh
none of those names are right yeah fully
blacks out most of the intros by the way
dude i think a couple more patreon
members follow's going to finally get
that class ring you can never afford
yeah i'm showing that thing
awesome we'll say in 94 shout out to the
trojans
but that could not be neither here nor
there gang we're back with a family
episode we got a hot one little company
in the house a little class in the
[ __ ] building
a fantastic good friend of ours uh this
gentleman is a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian podcaster
and actor
as you know he is the host of the versi
effect he is the co-host
of anything better with mr bill burr he
has an amazing comedy central special
out right now called i'll say this
and this thursday through saturday he's
going to put the addison improv
in dallas texas if you haven't gotten
[ __ ] tickets make sure you [ __ ] go
and see him because he's one of the best
guys a killer and also may 20th through
may 23rd he's gonna be at side splitters
in tampa
bay florida do me a favor give me a
[ __ ] nice big round of applause for
the
classiest the boss is here in
westchester new york
give it up for mr paul versus everybody
all right
first of all let me just start off by
saying i [ __ ] told you [ __ ]
i told you [ __ ] [ __ ] this show
was a hit
i [ __ ] it i was one of the first ones
on here all right with the beginning of
the pandemic whatever it was
kevin calls me up hey you want to do
this thing yeah of course i'm going to
do it i love you
i get on and i'm thinking i'm doing a
normal podcast and this is the truth
this is actually all jokes aside i think
i'm doing a normal podcast you shoot
this [ __ ] with your friend
you're gonna sit down you go well yeah
remember that story greg
how'd you get started yeah yeah yeah uh
yeah i'll see you later great remember
that one time we did it meanwhile the
whole [ __ ] thing was set up
this is what we're gonna talk about and
you guys brought me back
to uh when my parents were divorced you
brought me back to when
we were kind of broke me my mom and my
brother and all this [ __ ] and but it was
fun funny you hit on questions that i
didn't think you were going to hit on
and i told you i go yeah
this [ __ ] show you gotta it's gonna
be you gotta hit i guess
yeah i wish there was a [ __ ] betting
i wish i could have called it and put
[ __ ] money on this investment sounds
like paulie wants a nickel and a patreon
that's a couple of goons out front of
the door i didn't want to come out and
say it but you know just [ __ ] float
me a honey
did he did not say it was going to be a
hit did he say he was going to be able
to float me a honey
i'm stealing that listen float me a
honey i'm paying for parker for this
[ __ ] today
all right you [ __ ] suckers at least you
could have done is come up to my [ __ ]
house and do this
it's gonna cost a good 55 for this
[ __ ] hour and a half
speaking of your house uh paul is an
extremely classy gentleman humble
beginnings as we as as we know
but extremely [ __ ] classy does it
nice does everything nice
does it nice and i can't remember where
it was but you were saying
you were saying something like if you're
at my house and you don't have a drink
offered to you in 30 seconds yeah
yeah when you walk in my front door this
is the truth and i take pride in this if
you walked in my front door
like if i said hey you know foley kevin
i want you to come up to the house
thursday night whatever when you showed
up to the house 5 30 6 o'clock thursday
night when you walked in
there's a platter of cheese and meat
there's a platter of meats and cheeses
that's out yeah then there's multiple
bottles of red that you choose
okay you you choose i ain't making you
drink nothing dude you want a [ __ ]
pinot noir or a [ __ ] cow what a pinot
noir
oh did i [ __ ] i'm getting excited i'm
sorry i'm coming in a little hot
okay just come on down to verges we got
pinot we got cab
we got sauvignon blanc whatever you want
i got chianti all the [ __ ] so
uh yeah that is a very big part of like
me being a host sure yeah
is because i just want you to go [ __ ]
like not only did we go up to the
country we saw
nice scenery but we [ __ ] we had we
whined we dined
we just did it like that's how you got
to do it because are you going to
remember that's an experience
he's a big experience he's a big
experience yes
i'm about like the memory like so
so kevin and i kevin opened for me in
houston mm-hmm and
you know i heard buddy i like a cigar
like brave reviews
i like a cigar lunch after a show and
but we did the cigar thing one night and
then i was like kev do you want to go
and get a drink and he goes yeah and i
go you want to go to a wine lounge and
he was like what
and and i was like let's go get wine
it's not like a dave and busters
i got a basketball game there can you do
it do you do the quick
i got dibs on the skee ball huh
yeah you were like yeah but then we get
there and it was literally like we were
on a date it was
like there was like dark lights it was
dark leather couches and [ __ ]
they had matching like cheeses with the
wine like it was a [ __ ]
but then we sat there and they brought
us the wine and they brought us the
cheese and the meats and we just were
like
oh my god this is he'd be like
mid-conversation he's like shut up right
there grab this piece of meat
with this piece of cheese it's all about
the combo then the sip of the wine does
something in the middle opens it up and
the waiter there was telling you like
hey if you like this wine
yeah no kevin's right your memory is
good because i go i go just eat that
real quick
and i'm like i'm like telling him about
my family life and [ __ ] he's like
[Laughter]
he puts the gorgonzola in his ah that's
fantastic now will you guys do that
because i imagine you and the misses
kids are in bed it's a friday night or
whatever if you're home or
off night you'll do that nice just
together you she'll put the cheese plate
out
for the two he is on the back deck or
something yeah yeah the the thing is
with us and i told my wife this is very
this was out of the gate
there's no days of the week to the versi
house oh i like it do you understand
we've got it we'll go with this day
tuesday's a wednesday what do you mean
out of the gate first date or like
walking down walking down the aisle
like when no like when we were married
to get married i just looked at her like
you know who you're dealing with here
right right yeah she knew
and but like and this is true a monday
night
we'll get dressed and we'll go to a big
sushi dinner on a monday school night
it's
like it's a saturday night i like that
that is because you got to live like
that
yeah you know if you have the anxiety
that's only monday oh [ __ ] then it's
tuesday you're not living
yeah you got to [ __ ] that's good you
got to listen it hypes me up
yeah you got to live like you you could
be tuesday and be like you know what
we're gonna [ __ ] do
and your wife's like what you're just
like we're going to that restaurant
we're going to that you put your nice
[ __ ] [ __ ] on because we're going out
i'll buy [ __ ] two bottles of food
well even even before we started
recording he's like what do you guys
think it is i'll get a stick i'll get a
steak dinner i don't care
he said i'll get off looking at a
[ __ ] steak a 400 bottle and what's
the most she ever dropped
on a bottle of wine do you know no i
won't go 400 the most i've ever dropped
on a bottle
like a bottle of cabernet with like like
200 or less a little less than 200
you know you get 20 i just dropped a
hundred yesterday for my brother's
birthday
it's definitely artemis oh that's good
no stagger but
like a lot of people talk [ __ ] they're
like oh you could get a good 12 up it's
like yeah you can but
you could get a great hundred fifty
dollar one yeah
yeah i heard this one's like 9.99 it's
like i'm not
fishing for the cheapest [ __ ] that's
okay
okay how about you drop too [ __ ]
honey and no it's okay
stop embarrassing me dude you have a
good time like someone's challenging you
to him
i'm not going to spend two bills on a
bottle tell me i won't
i'll be having a whole [ __ ] family
estate what's your mother's address
i hate to see you at disney how much for
epcot go ahead give me the whole [ __ ]
thing
go ahead i want the whole roller coaster
i want the whole roll i don't want
nobody on a roller coaster my wife will
[ __ ] give mickey a handy i think i
give a [ __ ] we're getting the whole
experience
[Laughter]
sorry i don't know why i went there but
i don't know why i put my wife involved
in some sort of fetish thing
when in florida what are you going to do
you gotta have a little fun down there
it wouldn't be the first time for mickey
would it
no i doubt it oh my god buddy thank you
so much for coming back and sitting with
us gang this is a family episode so
we're going to be answering your
questions from the patreon couple from
the facebook group
we love you guys thank you for all your
[ __ ] support man this is uh
this is a wild ride by the time you hear
this we'll be [ __ ] halfway to
nashville baby
yeah we'll be happy nashville maybe yeah
it'll be over we'll be home when this
comes out what are you talking about
let's see what homeland security has to
say about that could be getting roughed
up by a couple of tennessee good old
you know it couldn't happen seriously
though this couldn't happen to two
better dudes man
you too like there are certain people
when you go out and you see them in the
clubs and
you uh we talked about this on the versi
effect but you know i don't want to
sound repetitive but when i saw you guys
in clubs and i would talk to you guys
and stuff and i was like
these are just guys who are hustling
they came from philly
they have goals they're hungry and it
was and good dudes and then to see you
guys
you know get a winner thank you and see
that happen
and then you get to pass all those
pieces of [ __ ]
it is nice stepping over a couple of
bumps ain't too shabby
because what it is is there's people oh
let's just don't get me wrong don't get
me started
i'll [ __ ] i'll end up burning bridges
you get me paulie's got the zippo out no
but
there's something about when good dudes
for me
because i i've been in this game longer
than you guys of course
and i know when you're coming up and
nobody wants you
and you're getting this shitty spot or
hey yeah you know you could do this
tonight
and you're like really like all right i
guess i'll do it because you kind of
have to sure there's not much going on
you know
right it's like i'm going to take what i
could get what this city is going to
give me
what industry thinks i am i got to at
least get that now
because they don't know but you also you
know i'm thinking about too it's like
you can't blame somebody for not knowing
who you are and i don't mean
popularity-wise i mean what you're made
of sure you can't blame somebody
nobody knows your heart nobody knows
what you're what you're made of so when
they look at you like that it's like oh
that's their [ __ ]
that's not you yeah right that's that's
their issue because they don't know
you know what your makeup is but um when
guys like you
do this it's like it's vindication
because kev will tell you like there's
nothing i like more
than than when you [ __ ] go when
somebody's a [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] he's a real [ __ ] when
it comes oh
yeah i mean i got i just got a list i've
never heard [ __ ] and [ __ ] in the
same sentence
yeah no i have it yeah leave that out if
my mom hears that clip
it's going to be the promo club i mean i
have a vendetta i hold the crutch
and but like not in this not in a sick
way but in a way where it's like i'm
never going to forget you treating me
like a piece of [ __ ] sure yeah and then
you always remember because we always
remember who's good to us
sure but you especially remember who's
bad 100 and then when you start to do
stuff they either will get quiet
and retreat or fake and be like oh i
knew i love you guys
it's one of the two you know and so so
to watch you guys do what you're doing
and to see this thing
uh it's i i [ __ ] i love it and i'm so
happy thank you
you're one of our idols you're [ __ ]
one of our role models uh-huh we want to
do it like paulie does it
yeah by the way my wife would when we go
my this is my wife's favorite place
on earth uh wildlife because when we go
we get a house down the jersey shore for
one week in
august and every day she's like you got
to get me that old coffee from wildlife
like that that coffee let's be honest
though it's not really it's like a
milkshake it's yeah i don't know
it is not great it's so good it's
already in the machine
the iced coffee it's basically a
chocolate milkshake with a little bit of
caffeine
yeah but my wife she's like i'm on
vacation i don't care you packed out
with ice
and it's like 64 ounces
like a trash can oh yeah they're sandy
feeling flip-flops but i'll tell you
what man
as much as i [ __ ] on jersey the wawa and
and lbi where we go is kind of nice
everybody does give jersey a lot of [ __ ]
man and like you know now that
over the last year or two i've never
seen a beach
other than the jersey shore dude the
jersey shore you go to the
when you go there when you go to any
jersey shore it's filled during the day
with a bunch of [ __ ] trash
it's like all like roofers and
carpenters yeah and it's a lot of trashy
[ __ ]
my family included but when they all
leave and it's like the sun's going down
you're sitting there the [ __ ]
the sky's orange yes there's you know
there's not like a meth head next to you
you're like
holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] beautiful yeah
there are there are certain beaches and
certain
like uh like lbi has beaches where
you're like oh this is not it's families
it's not that but then you get that like
wild that's absolutely side
yeah it's like a slice of pizza this big
it's like a [ __ ] cotton candy machine
at the beach like that's the little yeah
i never thought about it that way the
bigger the slice this
year oh listen if you get a slice that's
two or three slices together it's a
[ __ ] yeah
come down to come down to nicki's slice
the size of your car
shout out to lorenzo's on south street
ah i love it is that the ver that's the
versey vacation
one week awesome so so we we sometimes
we'll go
to like another one but one thing that's
a definite is
one of the later weeks mid to late weeks
in august we go
to the end of lbi kind of and it's it's
really nice like the beach there's one
beach that we went to one year was
almost
it was like five families like it's
really awesome and it's like what
kevin was saying like at night like when
it's it's just like your time beautiful
we have the house right there so we
could just go and shower if a couple
people want to go back to the house and
hang sure other people want to sit there
like sometimes i'll smoke a stick or
just start
you know i'll start drinking coronas at
the beach before dinner of course
on the move my my family we do the same
word there's a section on my face
there's so many of us
that they do late nights at the beat to
the point where like dude they bring
like
they set up tents they bring lamps and
[ __ ] oh they got dark dude they got like
a generator going it's a [ __ ]
trash oh you mean like dark night time
like they'll no they don't like they'll
go at like
instead of going at like 10 to like
three or whatever
yeah they show up at like two and then
stay till like nine
oh wow and it's like dude they get like
pizzas delivered and they treat it like
they treat it like they're in a state
park dude they're like tailgating on the
beach is delivered
two families next to the lifeguard
he's got [ __ ] sand in his nike's
walking back to his car
eight dollar tip for this um
stendig family goes with you is it just
is it just just you guys
so we'll get the house for two weeks but
i'm there with my family for one
sometimes my mother-in-law will take the
kids okay for like uh like the first
week
me and my wife take care of [ __ ] at the
house make sure we got you know the
the pets and everything done then we go
down and then it's just us
and then and then like you know my mom
somebody opened my stepfather will pop
down for two nights we'll all go to
dinner
one time you know my older brother so
it's just kind of a tradition that we do
but he's [ __ ] crazy he's collecting
who picks up the bill when you go out
with your mom you got to do that now
right
so here's the thing so they wanted to
like they wanted to stay at our house
and and for like down the street they
wanted to come and stay
so i'm like yeah come on like i'm you're
my my mother's stepfather like of course
you're gonna stay take one room
it's like oh you know but it costs like
you're not gonna stay at hotel you're
gonna stay with us so then they would
insist on what one night we're going to
we're going to buy the dinner
okay yeah and i'll be like no no they're
like no no we're staying here for a
couple nights for free so
so like that's their way of like they
want to do that sure of course
you're going to make them still feel
nice that's for them to say face and
that's it's sad man that's
that's really a dying like thing like i
i always remember that with like my
uncles and my dad or like my aunt
same situation if like my aunt and her
uncle came down from like wilkes-barre
to stay with like my mom's house
in the summer they had to go out they
were going out to dinner
and we're paying for it or if we went
down to like my uncle's shore house
if they had a short house for a couple
of weeks and we did the same thing we
stayed for a night
they'd be [ __ ] fighting over the
check yes they'd be fighting over it
and now these [ __ ] kids these days
yeah with two on this and
you know what i mean they're [ __ ]
well we didn't eat oh we we just we
didn't
yeah it's like you can't for them that's
almost like my parents vacation money
yeah yeah yeah yeah and we're like even
though you don't have to stay there like
no no we have some things that when we
go out we do so
let us do that plus it makes them feel
good with the kids
yes of course you know like their
grandkids and they're like no no guys
we'll go to this place and we'll do it
so
and everybody wins because everybody
loves being with each other we hang out
you know sometimes like me my stepfather
will go golf
or something one day but that's the one
week that no matter what's going on
whether there's another vic that week
happens yeah yeah you know yeah i love
it it's class
gang real quick when we talked about our
brand new sponsor we could not be more
than happy about it
helix helix sleep mattresses are
absolutely fantastic
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preference of the perfect mattress for
you
oh yeah best in the biz why would you
want to buy a mattress that was made for
somebody else which makes perfect sense
i've been sleeping on shitty mattresses
my whole life me too i know and you got
a brand new helix i'm left out in the
cold
we could have used two it's a two-man
operation but i'm glad that you have it
gang with helix you're getting a
mattress that you
will fit you perfectly that's the whole
that's their whole motto they're not
just throwing mattresses at the door
here you take this you take that they're
taking the extra step and talking to you
about what you prefer
what your body type is everybody's
unique and helix knows that
so they have several different models
several different mattresses to choose
from
they have soft they have medium they
have hard mashers they have matches that
are great for cooling
they have mattresses for everybody if
you get hot at night that's absolutely
fantastic
a helix plus mattress or helix plus four
helix plus side sleepers
like me yeah guys i took they uh we got
one me my wife got one we took the quiz
uh we were matched with the twilight
model
really it's best for us baby queen size
twilight came
comes in a big box it's easy peasy you
cut it open pop it open let it rest for
like two hours it's open at full size
sleeping like a baby fantastic that's
what we're doing so if you're looking
for a mattress take the online quiz
and order the mattress that you're
matched to and the mattress comes right
to your door
shipped for free you don't have to go to
the mattress store ever again and why
would you to be honest yeah no [ __ ]
middle hustled by some salesman
middle of a pandemic that shit's over
we're not doing that no more helix is
awesome
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick
of 2020 by gq and wired magazine these
are high quality publications we're
talking about
these aren't bozos off the strip guys so
just go to helixsleep.com
garbage take their two minute quiz and
they'll match you with a customized
mattress so they give you the best sleep
of your life i'm telling you
i got it two weeks ago i've been
sleeping like a baby they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk free damn
no fly by night corporation no pun
intended not too shabby yeah they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will i'm telling you
it's
awesome helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
garbage that's helixly.com garbage for
two
hundred dollars i ain't talking percents
i ain't talking nothing
two hundred dollars cash you get that
off plus two free pillows
check it out hey gang if you have a
problem at the house what do you do you
just let it go kippy squeaky door
busted dishwasher whatever you let it go
just sit there right now you take care
of it like a gentleman
oh you do you take care of it yeah it's
interesting so why wouldn't you folks do
that if you had a problem in the bedroom
i don't know
yeah you might be embarrassed you might
be scared to talk to your doctor we
don't have to worry about it anymore
gang
with getroman.com garbage let me tell
you something with roman
you can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for
ed all from the comfort and privacy of
your home yeah guys a us licensed
physician
health care professional will work with
you to find out what treatment is
best if medication is appropriate ships
right to your free two-day shipping no
questions asked maybe it's not
appropriate who knows we'll find out
the whole process straightforward
discreet no one has to know your
business
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com
garbage and complete the online visit
take care of your ed without ever
leaving your home
complete the online visit today and
connect with a healthcare professional
to take care of it go to getroman.com
garbage that's getroman.com garbage and
you'll get 15 bucks off your first month
again not percents we're talking 15
bucks hard cash cash
money times like this who don't need to
say who don't need to save 15 bucks it's
really
it's time to take care of your e.d for
good and remember get started today
you'll save 15
off your first order of ed treatment go
to getroman.com
garbage it's classy man he's a [ __ ]
classy guy i [ __ ] love him
uh let's get into some uh some cues here
for the squad out there
guys so as you know when you join
patreon uh we will ask your garbage
question it's just the only way to do it
we get so many [ __ ] submissions on
you know facebook everywhere else but
when you do join the patreon we will get
to your question
and uh there is a bit of a backlog i
know you don't like me saying that but
we're [ __ ] working through them
and so far and you don't owe them that
well when they join
yeah yes we do we only hear the pain
they're paying they're paying
stop the show that's
[Laughter]
we're talking about these classy people
patreon yeah all class on patreon
you guys literally started looking
around like i don't know he's joking
right
i'm out of here you start [ __ ] on
the regular view these bozos onto that's
hilarious i told you this guy was a bum
getter
so far the best question ever yeah we
just we just did it as a clip from last
week's episode
ever been ran over which is like if you
get ran over you're
you're not doing what you should be
doing you're doing you're on a highway
you have to know a couple of you know i
grew up with that guy
you know what that reminded me of uh
brett ernst you guys have brett ernst
brent yeah we did brett via skype dude
dude dude brett's bit about that kid
that's always outside
it's like even at midnight he's just
hanging on the corner like that's the
kid that would get run
over yeah i i've never no dude like
that's a crazy i'm trying to think of
even if i had a friend that get run over
but that's a trash yeah you're like
you're doing something you shouldn't be
doing typically it's bad parenting dude
you're not a shitty parent if your kid
got hit by a car
if your kid gets hit by a car you [ __ ]
up yeah well just to be clear it's not
hit by a car it's ran over right he's
got
it's gotta ran over ran over yeah
oh wait a minute so it's specific to
being ran
over so you're already on the ground
wait a minute you voted right now it's
open for interpretation
but ran over is different than hint it
is this is what we're talking about i
think you have to either go over the
entire car
or under the car yeah going under the
car is a tough one oh and under the car
you can't just get clipped yeah
everybody's been nicked by a car here
and there you know in a parking garage
two episodes we've talked about this
that's so funny that's so funny
i saw a kid i saw a kid this is true i'm
not saying this now it reminded me
i saw kids get dropped off in front of
the school
and his mother ran over his ankle
she just clipped them and i remember he
it was almost like shock he wasn't like
it was like a quick like a bum but it
was almost like what just happened
and it was and i remember seeing that as
you said that but i've never seen
somebody like
laying in the street full-fledged laying
there and then just getting [ __ ] run
over
hear the thump under the car yeah
where's ronnie
i see his hat
there's jordan there's jordan's in the
tree for some reason
to walk man floating in midair
[Laughter]
one shoe is on the [ __ ] oh that's a
bad sign man
you're missing a kid you find one shoe
unless he's limping around somewhere one
shoe is a bad look
what did you find we found one shoe yeah
you if you if you're in the search party
you keep that to yourself i'd rather
i'd rather find his pants
yeah one shoe is just a tough look
because he's somewhere hemmed up
that's the cover of a poster of a movie
of an abduction
of just the laces yeah it's just a lace
hanging and yeah
you're like oh i gotta watch this [ __ ]
yeah what happened to jimmy oh
man that's so cool i'd rather find his
pants
i'd rather find semen on a tree
the detective is just holding like a
jordan one
[Music]
oh my god oh my god this is too much fun
this is just the greatest
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] folly almost got a smith
thing
oh my god we're not even going to get to
a question
those are the best episodes oh
holy [ __ ] dude that was so fun we got to
smoke a stick after this
that's a tuesday i don't care if it's a
[ __ ] friday i'm putting a [ __ ]
suit right now what kind of wine you
want
tell the patreon people to kuwait we got
to stick to smoke look see the left just
goes see
how scared yeah yeah i got it come on
[ __ ]
i'm just gonna do it to [ __ ] with him
like it's a big laugh but then you say
patreon and they just
go
this one i feel like we might have
touched on it before but uh this is from
for
from verena uh is it trash to clap uh
after an airplane touches down or at the
end of a movie
you don't oh we have touched on we have
i'm sure at some point a bumpy ride i
think
you can clap if if if it's like
something where people were real i've
been on a couple because i'm almost on
like 40 flights a year i've been on a
couple
i was on uh an aborted landing where we
were literally
reportedly yeah when you go down no no i
mean when i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
this
i'm going to i'm going to [ __ ] you
know and mark mark tashera
the the yankee first baseman yeah he's
an announcer now but he was on the plane
and he was like yeah dude what are you
eating that comes
if i look over you're like hanging like
you're at a ball game cracking peanuts
what the [ __ ] you're getting too
comfortable we got mr percy here during
the show he goes like this a guy comes
over with a hot dog
he's like kind of open you got rappers
and [ __ ] i passed the change for the guy
um no got heartburn all his headphones
are hooked up to a radio
he's got the mets game going right now
he's like it's a three-two count their
bases are plugged
shout out to erin nola for throwing a
shout out
oh god so we're coming down we're coming
down in westchester
it's it was windy that's a small airport
to begin see i don't like that and
where we're flying tomorrow i'm real
worried about that plane from raleigh to
to
nashville man i'm expecting like a
puddle jumper no no no bricks a coke in
the [ __ ] tail
i don't like it well you don't yeah no
you it's that's that's not the problem
the problem is when you
like our wheels were here and the ground
is where the ground
we were i was five feet off the ground
people were getting ready
and just were about to touch and just
you shoot back up i mean you're almost
on the run you shoot back up and
everyone was quiet and nobody said
anything i'm like dude i just saw my car
like how is it like and nobody said it
somewhere we worked together i think it
might have been i think it might have
been yeah i remember
that and then he circled around and then
he came on he's like guys there was a
wind shears like basically what happens
is when the wind is going
over the wings as you come down it can
be he basically saved our lives by by
doing that because what would have
happened was he would have went down and
when he was trying to come down the wing
would have slammed the plane down who
knows if you die but it could mess the
plane up yeah
he's just like so he did it he did it
again and that was just like
holy [ __ ] so in a situation like that
maybe a few people clap
um the end of a movie you just don't get
out enough
was that the first movie you ever saw i
mean i mean
it's what movie could you clap at the
end i did it once
the first avengers like everybody
clapped oh i saw the i took my wife
girlfriend at the time to see the remake
in manhattan of scarface
and when he came since it was such
already an iconic thing people erupted
during the scenes
that they knew but it was like it was
like it was almost like uh
like a like a celebration celebration
about goodies like when he was like
getting interrogated at the beginning it
was my name is tony montana people would
just
because it was just it was such an
iconic thing so i guess that's kind of
different they
already issued scarface in theaters they
re-issued it
they re-released it in theaters for like
a week or two weeks and you were dating
yourself and me and
and i said i was like oh there and she
goes i never saw that movie and i go you
never saw them it was like
she's a classy if a woman woman
shouldn't be going to see scarface
but man yeah you know what i mean you're
if your wife has like a scarface poster
in high school or something wrong
that's a real italian move though right
i mean like if your wife
knows scarface in the 90s
she sold coke at some point she ran coke
for somebody for her previous boyfriend
well at any point have you had a
scarface poster
no guy's all classed no he's all classy
no
no i would imagine sports would have
been yeah like i had like i remember
having i think i had like a shawn kemp
poster i've had like i've had like
certain
jordan sure so sports posters i'm trying
to but i was never like a movie poster
yeah type of guy there were some movies
where we walked out and instead of
clapping
like me and my brother or we'd be blown
away yeah they'd be like holy dude that
was funny you know or like
did that to me or even a tear i'll even
say this maybe you get like
choked up by something yeah but to to
just like start going like that
i've seen it happen but i think it's
trashier to do that than the plan it's
one of those things that yeah
well your life's on the line you know
what i mean yeah you're 30 000 you know
37 000 feet in the air then you come
down and it was a little rough
i'll give you that right if you're happy
and how something panned out for a guy
who doesn't exist on a screen
you can [ __ ] act like you've been
there before you know i love that kevin
mcallister
yeah every time with him
that's good um all right this one's from
sideshow bub
uh when was the last time you've been to
a hooters
oh well i went to a hooters because
that's how every answer when hooters is
brought up well actually
uh yeah no so you can't say we go every
wednesday you guys know chris lamberth
yes yeah yeah comic right uh he's he
lives in he lives in jersey
and chris and i we we're movie fans so
we go to the movies a lot
and uh one time we left and we were like
dude i'm hungry
and we wanted to watch the ufc fight too
and the hooters was the only place sure
that's how they get that's all hooters
so we were just there and i was like
i'll get some wings and hooters and we
went there and then all of a sudden
it wasn't that packed and the fights are
on and i was like all right this is not
so like if you plan a hooters it's tough
and it's like a you know it's like it's
already in the sub you know what i mean
weekend we're hitting
if it's a premeditated hooters visit
plan
yeah yeah if you're like dude thursday
i'm picking you i made reservations for
four we're great we're [ __ ]
there reservations is straight garbage i
said in the leslie section make sure we
get leslie's section
that was always the saddest thing man
yeah a straight you fall in love with a
stripper on a friday night or something
like that with a couple in you
i understand that but i knew a couple of
guys that like really thought that like
the
bartender or whatever it like or even
like at the local bar
oh yeah or if you know what day of the
week the soup is
as [ __ ] yeah like if you
know like that like you're like
wednesday it's fresh she told me yeah
you know yeah that's to you when you
frequent it a lot that's when the good
clams come in
this is actually a perfect person i had
this thought and you're a perfect person
to give the judgment on this
yeah is it trash or classy to have a
usual
at a spot you walk into a spot you say
the usual is that classy or is that
trash
you mean you mean usual meal or usual
sit sitting
where you sit i would say usual order i
think that's pretty classy
it depends on the if you're walking if
foley's walking in a [ __ ] burger king
he says give me the usual
which there's several locations that
that i could do that with
but if you pop into like a bar or like a
whatever
it's not like a hooter it depends on the
place yeah
if it's an okay place it's pretty clean
because if my usual is like a certain
red wine
and and like an appetizer it's all right
but yeah so i think that
that depends i want to know what is that
where's the place obviously you and your
wife have a couple places up there that
you guys go to a lot
there's an italian restaurant up there
uh karachi which is
which is incredible yeah but i wouldn't
i wouldn't say that i have a regular i
mean i'm a you know there was a a veal
dish that blew my dick off
i mean i couldn't believe what i was
buying it's so classy and so trying to
pull my dick off
this [ __ ] veal blew my dick off i was
biting this thing and every bite i just
kept going i can you believe this
i just like when he's eating and it's
good he gets oh
dude how about that day we yeah we went
out i think we might have talked about
it on the first one that we did we went
out we had like true
best meal of my life they the guy came
over gm he came to the show or whatever
he came in he's like oh what do you guys
want to give us some menus and we're
like what do you recommend
i just took the menu and just started
bringing out food yeah and every time
dude
he loved that every course he had a
different wine and he was stuck
oh my god he's getting the booth behind
him like you should get a load of this
there is nothing better though going out
to a nice [ __ ] restaurant
that does it [ __ ] right having a
couple drinks getting like that that
first alcohol buzz
the appetizer that's honestly that's one
of the favorite things me and my
girlfriend love to do i know i'm fat and
all that stuff
but we love to go out to a nice
restaurant we both really appreciate it
and enjoy it it's [ __ ] fantastic
it really and and i think the older you
get the more you because you slow down
more yeah
the look on your face when they set the
dessert on fire it was like they just
brought you a puppy they set the dessert
on fire and we took a picture of it and
you were just
like oh he's got a picture i got a
picture of it and you're just like i
mean the guy just kept commenting
you've never seen that you've never been
to a restaurant where they set the
my mom's burnt cupcakes before but not
on [ __ ] purpose
no he this guy did it so right and like
there was that little bit of like
is he gonna charge but it was like
what's gonna happen when this is
so like so that but now oh this is great
because he's nervous because he doesn't
want to look like a [ __ ] jerk off
right
right you don't want to go like out is
the bill going to happen or whatever
so he's nervous because he doesn't want
to look like the guy the gm came over
and said
you escaping the men so i don't know if
we talked about on the show i'm gonna
break the whole thing down as quick as
possible
okay so um when i first got to houston
kevin had not arrived yet i got there
the night before
okay and i wanted to see the nick game
okay so i went into this bar and i said
it was busy and like they were really
kind of rude and brash not at this place
okay but i was like it's a nick game
entry because i'll find out and just
left me standing there for 15 minutes in
the same thing gotcha she's like
treating me like [ __ ] so i was like
whatever so i walk out you're dead to me
and i see this lit up seafood restaurant
and it's like lit up and nice and car i
think the valet park and everything i
walk in there and it's really like i
wasn't even dressed i just want to see
and this guy walks over nice dress suit
and i go yeah i'm just scared
he'll say let me see and i was like i
know i'm not dressed or i was just
curious i was like
they were kind of shitty but he goes
hold on and say and guy goes out of his
way
and like i mean out of his way to the
point where i walked up to the bar
walked around people
dining and i'm trying to figure it out
and and ultimately they didn't have the
nicki mm-hmm so i said let me tell you
something
[Music]
[Laughter]
that effort that you just gave me okay
cannot go
you know unrecognized so i said i'm a
comedian
i'm in town i'm about to improv i said
you and however many guests you want
and i keep it to four but i mean it's my
first
time bamboozled yeah i mean it's my
first week here so
you know that way you know that would
have really sucked if they were like
yeah he had a big party
showed up at a party bus i would like to
invite you and yourself
i'd appreciate it if it was a one top
but
[Laughter]
so gang this spring and this summer it's
time to get back out to the outdoors and
everyone has been cooped up inside for
oh yeah
it ain't good uh you want to do that
with your friends from bespoke post on
all your adventures
with a new line of essential box of
awesome collections
just for guys yeah guaranteed to upgrade
your life we got one they're absolutely
fantastic
whether you're out to taming the
wilderness or you just like doing uh
home improvements and you want to take
your home improvements from amateur to
pro level stuff
bespoke post has the answer for you
bespoke posts only sends guys the best
stuff
every single month no matter what you're
into every box of awesome has you
covered from style and grooming goods to
bar wear to cooking tools to outdoor
gear
their box of awesomeness collections for
every
part of your life yeah they sent us a
duffel bag i've been kicking her i'm
taking it out on a roll with us this
weekend baby
the weekender bag it's cool it's canvas
it looks cool looks
they got stuff that looks cool it's
really what it comes down to and it's a
good price
so to get started take the quiz at box
of awesome.com your answers will help
you
well your answers will help them pick
the box of awesome that's right for you
they got new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories so whatever
you're into they got it
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel at any time
each box only costs 45 bucks but it has
over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
man what are we doing here we got
nothing we got great deals for you guys
go take the quiz yeah cool stuff start
doing cool [ __ ] do cool stuff what are
we doing here treat yourself like a
gentleman you want to be a gentleman i
got good stuff for you you get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter our
promo code garbage at the checkout you
know the deal
20 off box of awesome.com promo code
garbage
20 off your first box what's going on
gang real quick we want to talk to you
about a brand new sponsor here on the
show oh yeah that we couldn't be more
happy about
it's lucy nicotine lucy nicotine is a
company founded by caltech
scientists and former smokers looking
for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative finally tobacco
alternatives that don't
suck all right this is a good stuff the
good stuff they've researched and
developed for three years and they've
made this product for people not
patients they treat you like a human
being
lucy has created a nicotine gum with
four milligrams of nicotine
that comes in three amazing flavors they
have wintergreen they have cinnamon and
they even have
pomegranate fancy pants uh they sent us
some
it's really good pomegranates
unbelievable we've been using
it uh it helps take the edge off you
know i'm a big smoker and i'm trying to
make the transition to not smoking
anymore
and this is playing a role in it for
sure uh each and every flavor tastes
great it's convenient discreet no one's
got to know you're using it yeah
you know it's uh you don't stink like
smoke walking around like a dirt bag
you smell like pomegranate like a
pomegranate like a gentleman fresh clean
breath never hurt anybody
yeah guys so it's 20 21 time to get rid
of those cigs uh unplug your vape throw
out your old dip and get yourself some
lucy gum or lozenges this is the real
deal
yeah get rid of the vape stop with the
vape will you a subscription to lucy
comes directly to your door each month
it's simple you don't even have to leave
your house it's delivered on its own
uh are you garbage listeners our
listeners go to lucy.co and use the
promo code garbage nice they get 20
off all products on your first order
including gum and lozenges but
you don't smell like cigarettes you're
you have a healthy alternative to it
with nicotine
and you're getting a deal yeah guys uh
and also
a as a disclaimer we have to read this
product contains nicotine derived from
tobacco nicotine is an addictive
chemical
guys go to lucy.co and use that promo
code garbage
now back to the show
this guy this guy gets my number
i give him my number and he actually
texts me and he says paul this is
so-and-so from the restaurant
if it's cool me plus three would be a
part of your four i said i'm done
so i call up the club i said this guy's
coming this guy comes in
okay me and kevin go up there kill we
have a great show it's a great night and
the guy goes you come to the restaurant
i'm the gm
and we go but then it gets to the point
where it was like i was like if we're if
we were paying which whatever if i had
to see i
i didn't know that you had gotten him
you in his mind you bought him tickets
to the show
him and and his whole party yes so he's
not charged right but it's
just a discomfort it got to the point
where i was like like it would have been
hundreds
like oh it would have been for crabs he
had like the stone crab like he started
then he started pairing white wines with
the crabs
then he gave a dessert drink then he
[ __ ] lit a dessert on fire
i don't know what that guy's getting
paid
i don't know but i mean the the dude has
some kind of certification i mean the
dessert is flaming blue you gotta go to
some
sort of training it can't just be a bum
off the street with a blow
this guy comes out with a torch this guy
i mean so by the time we had f and we
had full entrees
so i'm going like this we each had steak
and
we had steak we had lobsters stone crabs
desserts
different wines he starts adding crab
cakes i'd start sweating i'm nervous
then i looked over at kev
at one point i'm like yo dude like even
if this is i'm going like i don't care
but if this is 50
off we're [ __ ] he's going but then he
starts doing it he's like all right well
if
it is 50 off to the tip it's like
there's just a lot of like i don't want
to look like an animal because either
way
we don't know the situation and you
don't want to look like an [ __ ] right
right
so then when the guy walked over and he
goes here's what you got to do with the
dessert drink then i knew i'm like this
guy's not going to
start putting on expensive stuff to us
to do it and it was completely on the
arm
i was really hoping mercy wasn't going
to be like let's split it
[Laughter]
no no i'm [ __ ] breaking even on a
weekend i'm [ __ ] here
can i give you the wreck can i give you
the rest after tomorrow you got chicken
fingers back there or something
i'll [ __ ] work here no but like yeah
so no i would have never made you
obviously
you spend a time but i'm going like and
and then the guy did it so we give a
great tip and they were like hey can we
get pictures and we took pictures and
just phenomenal but
back to your point fully when you have
an experience like that it's the memory
of years
because look i'm so detailed with the
memory of it and this is a few years ago
and when you have a dining experience
like that it's you just you remember it
as much as a shitty one yeah
you know 100 of course that was a yeah
this is the [ __ ] best
best meal of my life it's a [ __ ] good
time yeah it is it is a great time you
broke that down
like a dad talking about a muhammad ali
fight
oh yeah yeah it was serious i get it
from my father because my father is my
father is a whole other animal man
my father is a whole other you've never
seen
i would love him to do one podcast in
history because you've never seen
anything
my father is a whole other animal 100
sicilian zero apologies like does
i mean just you know my father [ __ ]
like loves trump
to the point dude if trump was throwing
babies off a building
my dad would be like those babies were
poisonous he knew it
he donny t knew well yeah what did those
babies do to him
he knew that those babies would be evil
to hurt the country
so he nipped it in the butt like but
like not he's not like here's a funny
thing though he's like super
like if trump did something stupid he
would admit it but my dad is just one of
those like
he's an old school but food for him is
fantastic you know and he can't stand a
small portion
we went out to eat once when he sees the
portion he just you could tell he just
starts looking around
you know he's just like i mean what am i
supposed one time he said dude it was
really embarrassing man we were in
florida
and uh he he got this veal dish right
and uh
i knew what was coming him stacey was
like i was like stacy you gotta
understand my dad could be a little
embarrassing and i saw the [ __ ] neil
calm i saw it get dropped on his plate
and i saw his face three ounces and i
swear to god dude my daughter's there
my wife and um you know my stepmother
and as soon as i saw it i just grabbed
my son i go you need to go to the
bathroom and i bailed
dude i bailed on my family i bailed on
my family because i the anxiety
and then i came over and then i came
back and my wife beat red
staring at me staring at me and i knew
something had happened
and i just go she goes you left me and
then apparently what happened was
my dad said to the guy excuse me can you
come here
and he said do me a favor remind me next
time i'm here not to get this
because i'm not a [ __ ] and i'm going
and i go
what and he goes i'm not i'm not a
little whatever you've got to whatever's
okay to say but i'm not that
so i i can't and i'm just and i'm just
going like uh
yeah that's why i went to the back
that's why i was [ __ ] every man for
himself at some point
[ __ ] you come on act like you've been
here lasagna was amazing and my wife was
just mortified and everything and then i
just looked at lucas and i was like i
got you back
that's [ __ ] awesome so back to the
original questions it's
hooters is trashy is that where it
started
this started at hooters i'm sorry no of
course that's the one i could
there's no way i would have recalled
hooters i've only been honestly i've
only been to a hooters once and it was
in atlantic city and i think it was with
you
oh my god that's the only thing trashier
than a horse
an ac was looking for a job application
oh my god the muscles were actually
really good
well i think it was the same thing we
popped into what we were down there
doing shows i think there was a fight on
and we were like oh i think hooters will
probably have the fight or the game or
it was something
but then it doesn't live up to it the
girls are never that hot
i went once i went once outside of that
i went to
one in philly like with my boys let's go
to hooters and i remember just being
like what the [ __ ]
what are we doing yeah there are two
things i'd rather go to [ __ ]
mcdonald's than the strip club
yeah yeah i don't want to combine hot
girls and [ __ ] food i i feel like a
fat so enough i'm sitting with [ __ ]
wing sauce on my face
trying to make a [ __ ] move and get
some more blue cheese at the same time
that's hilarious i never liked how they
had the open [ __ ]
kitchen too oh yeah there's just a bunch
of convicts staring
at you what the [ __ ] are we doing here
you like them titties huh
i went to a hooters once on the way to a
giants game because they wanted wings
and beer
so it's like so so it's like it serves
its purpose in a moment out of it
not great wings either no and the
breading of the wings is not good either
so i i agree i think it's if it's a
if it's a thing that you plan if it's a
premeditated hooters thing it's trash if
you just go
to deal with beer and wings because
that's where they don't then it'll
suffice
ultimate trash you have the usual at
hooters i would say it would be the
ultimate challenge
yeah you walked in and said i'll take
the usual yeah that's yeah that's a
tough one
um all right off look next one's from
brian
uh have you ever been to a gallagher
show or the blue man group
[Laughter]
i mean i have been to a gallagher i've
never been to eastern europe
yeah i've i'm sure i've talked i know i
guess i haven't talked about this
uh how could you have gone to a
gallagher show i opened up for a couple
of weeks ago
i still got some guys still doing some
good stuff
he's getting old though he's down to
lemons now
he can't pick up the huge hammer so he
uses
he uses a little one from ikea he
punches a tomato now
[Laughter]
oh man no it was uh we were in a fishing
tournament in jersey and he was the
entertainment it was like this big
tournament
and he was the entertainment and at one
point
i was wait i mean i was like 15. he dude
he was taking bite-sized snickers and
throwing them in the air and then he
just had a tennis racket and he was
[ __ ] cracking them out
into [ __ ] just wailing people in the
face i remember being like what the [ __ ]
is this guy doing
that's [ __ ] stupid what do you got to
sign a waiver before you go
he was just spiking [ __ ] bite-sized
knickerbockers
for this or something jesus the blue man
group no i always thought that was
trashy and stomp
stomp we'll stop people tried to get me
to stomp everybody's smashing trash cans
you wouldn't go no i i went to uh when i
was in vegas the one show i went to we
went in vegas is a little different
that's like what it's based on too
right like going to those shows but but
i would still pick like i still wouldn't
if i was there and gallagher was there
and that's no disrespect to blue man
grouper gaga but i went to that chris
angel magic show
and dude it was i mean it was like
there's a double like it was like
[ __ ] three this year it's like he's
here then here i'm like that's not the
same guy
it's like that guy's six five this guy's
my height like
but yeah it wasn't like but no i mean i
don't know if it's trash to go to either
of those
chris angels chris yeah i mean yeah but
that's vegas vegas
in itself is kind of trash like vegas is
a tough
it's not thing you can you'll hear is it
you can do vegas very classy yes
if you don't do it classy yes it's trash
that's that is the 100
vegas can be done right yes but most of
the time it's done wrong by everybody
i i agree i would have to agree with
that but as for us it's different
because if we're performing in vegas
and the club goes hey i got tickets to
the show and you're like all right
i don't want to drink tonight i drank
last like i'll go to it and see it like
that
but i wouldn't go to like i wouldn't
seek a blue man group or a gallagher
show i wouldn't [ __ ] be like we're
driving
you're not delaware tonight you're not a
front scout looking for a scalper or
something like that i need two
i need two for f yeah up front for
hold on this we can combine two
questions here another one was
um has anybody in your family ever been
married in vegas
i don't know who that no not not in my
family now i feel like your review of
las vegas would be like chris angel's
not magic you know what's magic the
oysters at the border
that's magic that's magic that's mad out
of here what they do what they do with
the cocktail sauce that's bad
oh i did you know what i should actually
bring this up on your show i did one
thing that was i don't know if it's
trashy but it's real kind of ginzo
well that's it that's the line is that
young's toe online of like
very well i gotta tell you calling out a
magician at the show
[Applause]
i know a guy in a bronx that's been
doing that for 30 years
[Laughter]
he's called magic steve that's what we
call it that's not a goat that's a dog
what are you doing
come on uh no what i did was
i asked stacy for christmas i asked for
oh this is gonna be bad he can't even
get it out i asked stacy for christmas i
said i want new
floor mats for my lexus so like so
because you know they say like it'll say
like lexus es on the thing but like
my car was you know a few years old so
it gets worn
and with kids and mud and all that so i
was like you know what let's not just
get the typical
so on my christmas list i was like can
you get the model car
and get the lexus new floor mats for the
car and she got him
but that can that go classy too yeah
that's on the line of like because when
do you ask somebody for floor mats for
your car
yeah it's a cheap way to upgrade your
car is ultimately what it is yeah but it
is only rugs so i'm not trying to get
one overall
you know it's only like probably
whatever 75 dollars and it's only the
two
it's only the the driver's side rug
because the ones in the back are small
it's the drivers and the passenger side
rugs okay i don't know i can't make a
ruling
i don't know now is it the same mod is
do you have an es
yes okay no i haven't yet well i'm not
gonna get maybach [ __ ]
floor mats mercedes s550 and throw it in
my
lexus but no it's the model of my car
it's the from the factory and it
my car is always kept clean and you know
i like to get it detailed and cleaned a
lot
so since those were kind of ripped and
kind of shitty looking i was like let's
get
new ones make the car look good and she
got it but that i feel like that could
go either way
i say it's classy i say the only way it
wouldn't be
is if yeah if you change i think thank
you guys
i guess what's what's trash you would be
if it's a honda civic and you put the
lexus
exactly yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
it's like getting a tailored wife beater
it's like the nicest way to do it yeah
that's the nicest way to do it would be
to [ __ ]
get it through the factory what'd you do
with the old ones
uh you're gonna put them in the jeep
no if you made it welcome to my jeep
lexus it's gonna be your parting gift
when you come to the house
if he made it like a rug in the in in
the garage that'd be trashy
you get two types of red wine you choose
floor mats for the right hand
[ __ ] both of you take a floor man
stacey find out what cars they have
they're not leaving here without new
floor mats for the first one i want the
exact model
be like this is a rusty piece of [ __ ]
but the inside of this thing is nice
look at this floor mat
oh god i'm sweating yeah
foley had a 91 saturn but i'll tell you
what that rug
my dad got married in vegas remarried in
vegas which is tough whenever you're in
your parents
when you're in your parents wedding it's
a tough look which they are now divorced
they are not divorced yet wait your
father's second marriage
no my father yes so my parents are
married got divorced and my dad got
remarried
in vegas in vegas at the bellagio okay
bellagio it was not it was de blasio it
just opened but looking back
i remember thinking we were like the
kings of vegas looking back
it was a little it was like next to a
gift shop i know but he didn't get it's
not like he got married
you could buy a [ __ ] bellagio t-shirt
right now they give you a dice and a
deck of cards
good luck when you're married it's got
the date on the dice
um and then we did see uh what was the
the couple with the lions i don't know
if they were coming
roy we went to a stick freedom roy show
and they sho
i just remember when you said you would
saw chris angel because you were like i
pointed it out i was a kid
and they dude the lights went out lights
came back on and the one was on our
table
i don't know how the [ __ ] he did it
one of the things was like he was going
to relocate he was on the stage with the
tiger and then he relocated
literally to our table wow standing i
didn't hear any [ __ ] silverware
banging around
nothing lights came on this [ __ ] jerk
off and tights is standing on my chicken
that's how you meant to tiger yeah but
see i think there's like 15 siegfried
there's 15 rules it's just like one's at
the buffet you're like dude did you just
gotta
work i'm on break jerk off
jesus christ there's no such thing as
magic give it a break there's no way
these magic guys don't have stunts
because i remember the last trick chris
sanders i didn't really love the show
and i don't mean to i hate [ __ ] on
any performance thing because that's
what i do
like we do performance but like i
remember being like uh whatever and you
heard reviews and i wanted to give him
the benefit of doubt cause i watched
that show whatever
sometimes when it was on a e and then i
remember the last trick he did
did blow us away it was like he was in
one place and then another is like oh
[ __ ] but then you're like oh it's two
got
like yeah you have to when reality sets
in yeah how did that work
like there's there's an answer it's
impossible yeah yeah
i wonder what those guys do like when
they're not
like if you're just like hey dude like
what do you do and you're like i'm chris
angel every
wednesday i'm a mind free oh oh what the
other oh i'm talking about the other guy
just like eating lunch probably can't
tell anybody yeah
yeah i work at the casino yeah you know
what i mean yeah i guess he's got to
write in a contract that like
yeah it's probably a [ __ ] mountain
you got to tell your mother somebody's
got to know
listen don't tell nobody okay mom i need
this off i've been going to therapy
somebody has to know this
see i couldn't tell my mom that she
would eventually leak it out
oh yeah you know henry's the other chris
the next
the next thanksgiving picture you went
like a title sorry i heard your chris
angel's night off
[Laughter]
oh that's great uh the married in vegas
question was from jay i don't know if
ever said that song thank you
uh yeah it is i guess unless you do it
right but again that's how that's vegas
in general if you
spend the money and do it right i
probably probably doing it right would
be you had your reception at the
bellagio
and you got married in a [ __ ] church
like a [ __ ] gentleman
or wherever you get married not at not
at one of the [ __ ] chapels
if you just have your reception at the
bellagio that's probably nice and close
i don't even know if there was a
reception
yeah you can't be like i do and then
it's like yeah [ __ ] crap
it was siegfried and roy that was the
next day yeah
the honeymoon was sick freedom i had the
best one of the best steaks of my life
at the mirage though and it was like a
six hundred dollars
it was like a six it was like four of us
it was like a 600 meal but like the
steak was just so
yeah it's like you said you got to go
you got to do it you got to get the
highest room
or one of the high rooms where like the
bathroom's gigantic marble
like the shower is huge you got to have
a buddy sleeping in the bathtub
yeah it's like the people that look for
the deal like dude we got a room in
mandalay for 40 nights
that's that's like okay great it's on
the first floor
it's connected to the lobby
it's where the bellhop stays when it's
hammered a couple of janitors sleeping
in there
you gotta take a [ __ ] i gotta get in
there shift starts in 20 minutes
there's i hope this is a no to each one
of you this is just funny this is from
stevo have you ever worn any clothing
with snow camo on it
snow camo yeah like the white gray and
black camouflage but then snow
camouflage
that dropped in like the late 90s and
rat it was big with rappers
no and it was like if you're doing that
you're trying i actually have though
like one of the
masks during this pandemic was like
those
you know the ones that aren't masks
they're like the thin almost like a snow
oh like a yeah yeah yeah i have one like
that that that has that it's like thin
so you could breathe through it in the
winter or whatever
that's okay yeah that's all right yeah
that's like more of a functional but
you're talking about like
you're not camo pants yeah you're not
rolling up to like the [ __ ] bar and
like no
like you know timberlands and like snow
camo bmx yeah rest
[ __ ] arctic soldier yeah
uh yes rest in piece of dmx that two was
the best oh man that one hit hard
um this one's from brian marshall being
in the burbs
have you ever left your trash yeah from
brian have you ever left your trash bin
on the side of the road for longer than
a day
after pickup i'm assuming you run a
pretty tight ship
when the trash guy comes you're out
there to get the cans and bring them in
oh you know what where we live and my
driveway is gigantically long and all
the neighbors there's
there's been like a if if it's on the
mind
like it's one of those where like it was
it won't be out for the until the next
time yeah
but like a day or two you know depending
on my schedule if i travel lord knows my
wife's
making me do it yeah yeah so my wife was
so i think it depends but if we're home
and we clearly see it yeah we'll get it
okay i was always pretty good
i hated it i hated doing my drive wasn't
even that big but as a kid that might as
well been [ __ ] 30
miles long going down and get the trash
cans like what oh dude you could land a
cessna in my [ __ ] time here
he's got a you got a big nice piece of
property up there yeah yeah it's it's
it's a long walk and i like it though
because i use it as exercise and [ __ ]
but there's just sometimes i'm just like
uh you know and i got a little bit of an
issue with some of my garbage men
so wow that's trash because there's
there's some [ __ ] that like i wanted
them to like do and take
and like they're the type where if it's
not not defy the rules it's not if it's
like even like a little bit not by the
perfect rule like they'll leave
something
and it's like i'm tipping this kid on
christmas big really oh yeah i
tip big we leave an envelope we leave an
envelope taped
cash on christmas and the and the dude
gets cash so it's like listen
if if there's extra you know cardboard
that's not
perfectly folded in the thing and
there's just a little box out there it's
like you could
one hand washes the other and sometimes
they do but other times i could tell if
he's in a mood or whatever
like they won't and and that that kind
of you know so oh that would piss me
yeah [ __ ] off especially when you're
wetting a guy's beak
yeah yeah a wet beak you look the other
way on everything i mean and we give
cash
yeah you know there's no there's no
dunkin donut coffee carts
you know we're not giving this guy a 25
mocha [ __ ] discount
you got the [ __ ] 300 didn't you yeah
if you shut up yeah
keep it [ __ ] don't ask questions yeah
no [ __ ] that would piss me off too
yeah um all right this is from uh sean d
do you or have you ever been a nail
biter
which i do i bite the nails oh my god
religious yeah but i
i mean that's a tough that's a tough
thing to say trash cause like
you could i also think it's a nervous
tick with people sure so if it's a
mental issue
like you ever see like lebron at the
yeah like they're like like athletes i
think that's anxiety i also think it's
an anxiety ocd thing yes like i think it
gives people comfort
or then sometimes like you'll be driving
and you'll be like ah [ __ ] i gotta and
i'll just i'll just bite it off and like
i i agree with you on that but i have to
admit that i
yes i have those things i have ocd i
have anxiety but i also i'm also
disgusting
right so i i do i do like yourself sure
you're very disgusting i do like to bite
a good nail and also what i'll do is
i'll bite it like
three quarters of the way down and then
i'll use the nail to clean water
cut that out we're gonna lose patreon
members for that but listen if it's not
toenails i give a pass
toenails is a whole other world yeah
toenails is people know but people like
you ever see people clip their toenails
and like well that's
toenail clipping or anything with
toenails at all in public
is is it's a whole other world than
fingers i'm surprised
you're not a manicure guy do you go no
no i bite never you'll never
get them done i would never no i've
never done that really i've never got my
no i just you know i'm just more of like
you know like when they get long you
clip them in but i don't know like
my dad used to do that shit's hilarious
like some guys do it a lot of
i didn't realize a lot of athletes do it
get their hands no i'm not
i just had a pedicure for the first time
i'll go for a nice foot scrub i'll be
honest with you
really i've never no i've never had it
but that's how you could you could
i could i could like if because now like
it's more like men do it
yeah oh yeah so it's like scrubbing the
foot must be nice
it's great and the reason i actually do
it is because my dad's feet i love you
buddy
but it's they're like the toenails are
like blue point oyster shells
like a t-rex that's bad oh he could run
straight up a tree
it's like it's not gonna open doorknobs
with them yeah i love you
[Applause]
so my girlfriend up until recently she
you know she
she'll clip my nails for me she'll
she'll wow she'll do my teeth
your girlfriend do your toenails she'll
do my toes oh that's love oh it's real
i think it's more more functional to be
honest you can't get down for yourself
you have trouble putting your shots and
shoes on to get down there with a
clipper i would need like a shoehorn
with
a [ __ ] oxygen tank yeah i couldn't
get in there
it's like you're [ __ ] deep diving
yeah and and i couldn't do it for a
while
she wasn't like doing it on the first
date or anything like that it wasn't
until like
my toenails got really really long and
she was like why don't you clean your
toenails i'm like i can't do it she's
like i don't start doing it
so then she noticed that like the
cuticles aren't good and i don't want my
toes to get [ __ ] bad
when i get older i want to keep yeah so
i started getting peddies because they
they do the cuticles and the treatment
and they scrub the [ __ ] off the bottom
of your foot it's funny
it's funny you said that because that's
actually all jokes aside they say like
keep in keeping your feet in good shape
for when you're an old man
is a game changer yeah because it's like
for circulation and for all that stuff
plus you ever i mean one of my all-time
favorite things on this earth
is a soft pair of fresh socks out of the
pack
so imagine getting a scrub down and then
throwing a cushy [ __ ] new sock on
it's nice into a new sneaker oh
they put this camera it's a trifecta
yeah that's yeah you can foot scrub new
sock new kick
game over that's floating yeah it's real
nice
that's cool that's floating right there
it feels great it does because they
scrubbed the [ __ ] calluses off the
body
they put some kind of uh like chemical
on there that like almost peels it off
and then they scrub the [ __ ] out of it
yeah your girl loves you man
no she doesn't do that no no but i'm
saying for the fact that your girl is
willing
to even clip the toenails even if it was
a thing where you physically had an
issue with it
the fact that she's jumping in yes dude
at one time i said i probably shouldn't
say this but i
don't the fact that she sees me naked
doesn't throw up she [ __ ] loves me
i see you with clothes on and gag a
little bit
one time i was like man something's
wrong my ass man
i was like my ass is like it hurts like
my you know i was like i don't know
your butthole yeah like yeah like my it
was like burning i don't know if i was
eating and my wife was like you want me
to take a look at it and i was like no
but but the fact that she's just looking
like she was like and i'm like no you're
not doing you know and then i was fine
it was probably just whatever i was
probably probably
just ate [ __ ] tabasco or something
sure but i was like my stomach is messed
up my ass hurts like
and she was like oh look at it i was
like no no but that's like yeah was that
was that post kids at this point
no no no that was that was both like she
would do both like
if like right now two kids and anything
if i was like dude i gotta go get my
[ __ ] checked yeah she'd be like i'll
do it before you go to the doctor
damn dude my buddy got my buddy had
hemorrhoids in case the guy tries to rip
you off huh
you need new floor mats down here
my buddy got hemorrhoids one time and he
went in and they put him on
uh he's like it was like out of a bad
comedy movie
he's like do you mind if like
two of our uh you know doctors who are
learning like on rounds
watch and he's like yeah i guess right
he's like dude these two [ __ ] smoke
shows walk in
and now he's like i'm laying on a bed oh
that
like with i'm just laying on my stomach
and then the bed the head and the feet
drop
down so it's like your ass is up and
he's like dude my [ __ ] is just
bear exposed and these two [ __ ] smoke
shows they're doing a solo
yeah you just got to be like yeah this
is my [ __ ] [ __ ] like
wait when just to get checked for the
hemorrhoids yeah they had to like cut
off a hemorrhoid or something oh
yeah [ __ ] and he's like dude it was like
they were like porn star hot dude that's
like
sucks like if you see them at a
starbucks yeah two weeks later
hey paul how's the hemorrhoid doing oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
you could have been more gentle
uh all right let's do one more and then
we gotta wrap it up here this has been a
[ __ ]
barn burner that one's been great man so
fun man so fun
uh we've talked about this like what do
you keep at the house it was a recurring
one but this is from katie tyson
uh what brand of water bottle do you
pick up at the convenience store
if you're going to get a bottle of water
what do you do
it's i mean it also depends on what is
available because usually i've noticed
that like
aquafina places don't have don't always
have the fiji
or the you know gun to my head i'm going
feed
all day gun to my head you go feed you
just because i think there's one of the
things that like helps
one of the things in the in the what's
in it that other bottle waters don't
have
every water is actual spring water yeah
and it's like i think either minerals or
something that it has
is more healthy and it tastes good yeah
uh so i would always
if i had a choice of like i will tell
you it's got a cool bottle it's got a
good bottle it's there's a square bottle
we're bottling a little thicker plastic
we'll tell you what though
an aquafina's got a nice little
aftertaste
[Laughter]
wait is aquafina coke that's coca-cola
that's just that's just water from yeah
i don't like that bad news
i don't like awkward you're an aquafina
guy no i like the taste of aquafina but
my go-to
gun to my head my go-to i would say i
would say fiji
aquafina poland spring those are my
those are my
facts my least favorite and people say
it's also good for you is the avion
like the aftertaste i just can't i know
that's that's the real deal
that's the thing it's like the [ __ ] that
tastes like that they're like oh you're
getting more yeah yeah
yeah it has more uh what is it called uh
alkaline or some [ __ ] yeah something
like that but i like a nice perrier
carbonated
oh yeah yeah sparkling wow i love dude
pellegrino and we kept the bottle we
bought chas a bottle yeah like that like
everybody gets these if you're coming to
do the
ayg podcast you get these for a dollar
at the corner chas got the [ __ ] head
chas got the glass
i mean it's sunny you know you drank it
out of a red solo cup because that's all
we have yeah you guys
should have got him a nice wine glass
that's what he said because some
waterfront would have been nice
are you you're pellegrino at the table
right when they say what do you want
what do you know
now but just this year really just this
year okay they used to just be ice water
with lemon
i'm big on lemon and that's the greek
i'm in me too i go lemon all day okay
but uh now now that i've really
appreciated like a perrier
it's worth it it's worth it if ice cold
no ice cream when they say sparkling or
flat i go just bring the pellegrino out
yeah
yeah stop right there bring the bells
100 percent
now do you have those at the house well
if i would came up to your half we were
in the house
and i needed a collection yeah that's a
question
well we have two we always we have uh we
have cases of these
and then we also do the um the new brita
the kids get the because the kids are
always kids always need so there's like
a new brita that we have that like you
know and it's actually it actually is
nice
the brita the new one it's nice it
really when you see the filter you're
like oh that's what i've been drinking
yeah you know
um but yeah no so it would be like a
bottle like this or that but
i have a refrigerator in an off room
downstairs that's just loaded
it's loaded with it's loaded with
seltzers it's loaded with different
flavored sells there's it's loading
it's like it's loaded with coronas sam
adams it's just a fully loaded
you know anything you want ipa cans that
are ice cold
ice cold ipas new ipas i mean it's the
whole [ __ ] deal though
he likes a nice ipa yeah when you come
to my house you see the refrigerator
you're gonna [ __ ] stay there for
three days
but my brother blew me away yesterday we
went over to his house for uh
for for his birthday he had perrier in
the tall cans
i've never seen him never saw that no
ice cold dude they were [ __ ]
phenomenal
the that is the the game changer is the
is the
temperature of the drink like oh i tell
you honestly
i mean painfully cold i want my
esophagus to tremble yes
like painfully like i don't play i don't
drink beer
okay and when i do drink beer it's gotta
be ice cold
painfully cold yeah like not not like oh
this is a cold one
like you know the way the coors light
the thing turns blue i want it purple
i want they they haven't made the can
yet for the cold that i want yeah
i wanna i gotta wear gloves today
let me pair mittens and a sixer let's go
there's a hazmat suit
[Laughter]
oh my god gang what a fun episode paul
anything you want the folks out there to
know again you're going to be at the
addison improv this thursday through
saturday yeah guys uh if you're in texas
man addison improv um i will be
there this thursday uh for one show two
friday two saturday that's april 22nd
through the 24th
may 20th through the 23rd i'll be at
side splitters in tampa i'm doing a
bunch of shows i think seven shows out
there
i'm also gonna be in austin texas and
salt lake city in june you can go to
paulversie.com for that
please subscribe to my youtube channel
uh the versi effect is doing fantastic
uh anything better with bill burr is
doing great man i really appreciate
everybody so check all that stuff out
i'll be shooting a new special
um this summer should be out later this
year and in the meantime you could check
out my um clips for my first special
i'll say this so thank you
fantastic now most of you know paul if
you know us you know paul
but for the viewers out there that don't
you got to go [ __ ] see him he's
absolutely yeah he's a [ __ ] i've
opened up for
murder for so many weekends and he
[ __ ] bodies
yeah i appreciate that we love you buddy
i love you guys too man and i'm so happy
it couldn't be
a more fun podcast and it couldn't
happen to two better guys and i truly
mean that
thank you you guys appreciate it i hope
you take over all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
believe me there's a list not that i'm
thinking about that yeah
what are you trying to be positive over
here these [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh guys thank you so much we appreciate
all the support i'm at cameron comedy on
all social media
and then as you know please rate review
subscribe on itunes uh full video
available on youtube and then
patreon.com
we appreciate all the [ __ ] help yes
we do we love you guys and we'll see you
next week
[Music]
oh that was fantastic that was a banger
dude